- Welcome back.
Sometimes I save the best
stories for last you all.
This is what I'm liking.
(Drum music)
(crowd cheering)
After a year of remote learning,
most kids are back in the classroom.
But for one younger sibling,
the transition has been a little rough.
Eighteen months old Emmy seen
here with her older brothers,
was used to being around
them all day, every day.
All three are her heroes.
Now that the boys are back in school,
it's just Emmy and her mama.
And she waits for them to come home.
Folks, if you need a reason
to smile or cry in a good way,
this is Emmy's reaction when
they get off the school bus.
(excited kids yelling)
(crowd clapping)
I mean, what?
Let's say hi to Emmy
along with her brothers
Liam, Levy and Lucas and mama Brittany.
Oh my gosh!
So Brittany, this is the
sweetest dang thing ever.
And honestly, Emmy is adorable,
but seeing Liam and all of them
just run to her as well,
as the sweetest thing ever.
So does everyday look like this?
Is this every day after school?
- Literally every day.
She's our little COVID baby.
And she was born a month
before COVID started
and all those quarantine business.
So she's used to her entire life revolving
around these big brothers.
- Oh my gosh. That must
be like so drastic.
You know, it's all change.
So, to all of you, young men,
I mean, it seems like you
guys miss her as well, right?
Y'all are running to her.
- (unison) Yeah!
I got a thumbs up. Oh my God.
Well, oh my gosh.
You're the cutest family.
Look at that picture.
Oh my gosh. Well, thank you so much
for sharing this video, these pictures.
This is, it makes my heart smile.
It's so good for us to see
such magical little families
and also to remind ourselves,
you know, oh God,
I wish my kids did that.
They're like they love
when the other one leaves.
But I'm liking your posts
right now. All right.
And that's not all.
Our season long partner
Pilot Van Makers of G2,
the go-to pin at the Kelly Clarkson show
thinks your video is as sweet as we do.
So they're going to use
their G2 gel ink pen
to write you a check
for a thousand dollars.
How does that sound?
You can have a lot of fun with that.